this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four-hour body this is
more than 10 years ago and i did not get
paid to do so with approximately 75
vitamins minerals and whole foods
sourced ingredients you'd be very hard
pressed to find a more nutrient dense
and comprehensive formula on the market
it has multivitamins multi-mineral
greens complex probiotics and prebiotics
for gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stained and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you want to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it i mean
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever
so check it out take a look they've got
all sorts of cool stuff to choose from i
was skeptical and it actually worked it
worked much better than i could have
imagined and i'm very very happy so to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m dot
com slash tim all form is offering 20
off all orders to you my dear listeners
at allform.com tim make sure to use the
code tim at checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today is john dore
d-o-e-r-r you can find him on twitter at
john door john is an engineer venture
capitalist and the chair of kleiner
perkins as well as the author of the
number one new york times bestseller
measure what matters he has just written
his new book speed and scale
subtitle and action plan for solving our
climate crisis now this is something
that has really been on my mind and i'm
thrilled to have them on door was an
original investor and board member at
google and amazon helping to create more
than half a million jobs a pioneer of
silicon valley's cleantech movement door
has invested in zero emission technology
since 2006. he's passionate about
encouraging leaders to reimagine the
future from transforming healthcare to
advancing applications of machine
learning outside of planner perkins door
works with social entrepreneurs who are
tackling systemic issues across climate
public health and education you can
learn more about speed and scale at
speedandscale.com i recommend everyone
take a look john welcome to the show
thank you very much i'm thrilled to be
here
i am very excited to explore
many many facets of your life and
certainly current interests and i wanted
to start
with
perhaps the
first
visit or your relocation to silicon
valley
how and why
i suppose why most important
did you end up in silicon valley
initially
i came to silicon valley in the summer
of some graduate studies i was doing in
boston
and i came there with no job no place to
live and no girlfriend
my beloved anne had dumped me and fled
herself to silicon valley
because i was persistent is the way i'd
put it
and so she found herself a great summer
job at intel i didn't know where she was
working
and i too was looking for anne and
looking for a summer job so i rented a
55 a month garage apartment
in the hills above stanford and set out
to cold call my way into
some kind of summer opportunity
and this was just at the same time tim
you'll remember this that
intel invented the 8-bit microprocessor
the 8080 which was the
engine that ms-dos ran on and
microsoft basic and so forth
and lo and behold i got myself an
internship
at intel
and the first day that i showed up for
work guess whose office was down the
hall for mine
well ann holland she was not pleased to
see me
took the better part of the summer to
put the relationship together back
together i'll say
and now we've been married 43 years
[Laughter]
so that is a huge win and certainly
persistence rewarded
there are some other factors that seem
to also contribute to
another big win and that is landing
at intel
and also
getting to know andy grove for those who
don't know could you describe
andy grove and perhaps your first
impressions
andy grove
is a hungarian emigre he came to the
us with
literally nothing
enrolled in city college in
new york spoke broken english
studied semiconductor physics
taught that at uc berkeley has always
been an educator
and he worked at fairchild
semiconductor
the godfather if you will of
or the progenitor of the silicon valley
semiconductor industry when bob neuse
and gordon moore
left
fairchild
the so-called traitorous eight
the fair children resigned
to form intel andy grove was the first
executive that they hired initially he
ran operations ultimately he ran the
entire company
but he's arguably thought to be the best
manager and leader of his or maybe any
other generation
uh that very first summer that i was at
intel
i got to attend andy grove's courses
on intel he called them i opec for intel
organization philosophy and economics
and a particular
lesson that he taught
was how to get people to set goals to
get them
focused and aligned and committed and
tracking their progress
andy called these imbos intel management
by objectives
i call them okrs for objectives and
key results but
to make a long story short in the
semiconductor business
tens of thousands of people have got to
get lines a millionth of a meter one
micron right where nothing works at all
so
discipline precision accountability
stretching to do amazing things that was
all
a deep part of the intel culture and
this system
i took this idea of okrs when i left
intel everywhere i went i was the johnny
appleseed of the good gospel of andy
grove and so i had the chance to
introduce it to small companies and
large companies
to startups like the gates foundation
when it was getting started
to larry and sergey
in the very early life of google and
this is interesting because
our plan for the climate crisis is based
on okrs
objectives and key results we're going
to spend a lot of time on okrs and
discussing the climate crisis but before
we do i want to spend a little more time
on andy grove and your
professional development after intel
could you say just a bit more about
what made andy
a good or great
manager how did that manifest what did
you see
uh several qualities foremost among them
was he was an educator he thought that
leading involved educating your direct
reports and the entire organization
andy was extraordinarily disciplined he
was also ruthlessly intellectually
honest
and you always knew where you stood with
andy he was gifted and skilled at
confronting problems
without confronting people
sometimes and very often in business in
fact those two
distinctions get
unfortunately mixed up
during my first
summer assignment at intel my job was to
build benchmarks comparing intel
processors
to the competition which was motorola
i did that andy grove saw one of my
training sessions and drafted me to
travel with him
to europe to train the intel european
organization
and compete to win business at three
very large accounts
this was quite a heady experience a
thrill for as you can imagine a summer
intern
but he became
a mentor
a valued advisor
and gave me my fair share of tough love
when he gave tough love
this is something i'm trying to develop
as a skill myself candid feedback this
ruthlessly intellectual honesty do you
recall how he did that with you for
instance how he would deliver that so
that it would be perceived as being
tough on the problem but not abusive to
the person
it was always
balanced
but direct
so he'd say
john i love your potential at intel
but you have failed miserably to
communicate with the field organization
the crisis that we're having with our
16-bit microprocessor
andy had i remember when i told andy
that i was going to leave intel to join
a venture capital firm of all things
well
he had the ability to reach inside your
chest
and grab your heart hold it in his hands
in front of you and really question
not just what you were doing but why you
were making that decision
so
he was a role model for more than the
company far more than me i think for the
whole innovation industry
in his tenure
before you made your decision to become
a venture capitalist or to pursue
venture capital and please correct me if
i'm getting this wrong but
while at intel
you made what what people might think of
as an unusual request to be transferred
from the santa clara headquarters to the
chicago sales office
why did you do that if i'm getting my
research right you're right that's
impressive
my initial assignment at intel was in
engineering and then in product
management
but
through my career i've been really
blessed to have at any given time one or
maybe two mentors
and my mentor
jim lally
advised me john if you ultimately want
to be a marketing manager or general
manager
you're going to succeed or fail
based on your ability to motivate
others to get sales
to generate revenues to have happy
customers
and you're never going to learn that
skill if you stay in the factory you
should go out to the field take on a
quota carry a bag solve problems for
customers
sell make your commission or fail at it
motivate others to do the same
and so he pushed me out of the offices
it was a great gift
and i
decided i'd go around and hire myself a
field sales manager somebody to manage
my career
i settled on chicago
and
that year and a half
helping people succeed with intel's new
microprocessors
was one of the most gratifying times of
my career
was that an easy
decision
to make an easy recommendation to accept
the reason i ask that is that you have
technical training
and
coming into intel as an engineer at
least what i've seen in some places in
silicon valley is a disdain by the
technical for the non-technical for
marketing and sales on some level
did you see
the value in that recommendation
immediately did it make sense to you or
was there some resistance
yes i seized it there were a couple of
reasons for that
first of all i love people and
selling
consultative selling and i'm not talking
about flogging breakfast cereals but
solving real technical problems is a
very high calling
but the second is my father who's my
hero was also an engineer and a sales
leader and an entrepreneur so in many
ways my
career choices are reflections of
his choices and his great advice
one of the entrepreneurs i work with
genie kim at nuna says
she reminded me john when you're backing
the leader of an enterprise software
company
be sure that leader loves enterprise
selling
because it sets the tone for the entire
rest of the organization
that makes a whole lot of sense
and
i would love to
come back to the segway to venture
capitalist and i'm actually going to
read a little bit from measure what
matters and this
revisits that conversation that you had
with andy about your decision
so i'm going to paraphrase here just for
the sake of making it easy for this
conversation but
andy said come on door don't you want to
be a general manager own a real p l i'll
let you run into a software division end
quote so now your commentary is it was a
non-existent business that could have
been built into one and then he added a
zinger
john venture capital that's not a real
job it's like being a real estate agent
so of course
he knows how to push the buttons
he knows how to use the carrot and the
stick
but all this begets a question for me
which is why were you so interested in
venture capital how did you become so
interested
i wasn't interested in venture capital
what i understood was that venture
capital had something to do with
starting companies and i was hell-bent
as an entrepreneur
start
a company with friends with co-founders
because that's what my dad did and that
just made sense to me
so
after i interviewed with kleiner perkins
caufield and buyers which
sounded to me like a law firm they said
what we're looking for
door is someone with a strong technical
background
an excellent network
among brand name
silicon valley companies
who
has good people skills strong technical
skills have already covered that and is
willing to be kind of a gopher carry
business plans read them do whatever we
need to do to be successful
i responded well that's fine i would
join kleiner perkins but only if you
promise you will back me in starting my
own venture
and they said well sure we have a
long history of doing that genentech was
created in our offices tandem computers
so
we'd love to see
our younger associates
write plants and go develop them
and they they stood by their promise on
multiple occasions when i was fortunate
enough to help others start new
companies
let's
flash forward if we could to an
encounter that you you already mentioned
and we may fill in the gaps but
i think this is also perhaps a segue
into
further discussion of okrs could you
describe
your first meeting with larry and sergey
please
oh
yeah that was great i just committed the
largest amount of capital that our
partnership had ever committed at the
highest price
to two stanford computer science
dropouts
who had no business model
no idea how they'd make money
they were 24 years old
perhaps you can add
a rare photo that i have of them in
their garage but i was doing my gospel
of andy grove
okr johnny appleseed slideshow i
literally took andy's slides
and presented them to larry and sergey
at the end of that talk
i asked them for feedback i wanted to
know if they were going to adopt it or
not
and larry was
his usual
quiet self and
gave me no feedback whatsoever
sergey who was more brilliant and
expressive
well i'd like you to believe that he
said enthusiastically john will do this
actually the truth isn't quite that
what he said was
well we don't have any better way to
manage this company so we'll give that a
try
which i took as a kind of ringing
endorsement
because every quarter since then every
googler
has written her objectives and key
results
for the next 90 days
posted them on a public website
graded them from the period before
and shared them
and google does this to get everybody
focused and aligned
committed tracking their progress and
most of all tim
stretching for
amazing audacious
nearly impossible goals so a good grade
at google is is considered to be
70 or so
now at the end of a quarter what they do
is they sweep these aside
because very importantly they're not
used for bonuses they're not used for
promotions
they're used for a much higher calling
which is
to get a collective kind of social
contract
and getting everybody to want to do what
must be done
do you recall what was on those initial
slides was it copy and paste more or
less the same thing you just described
but those slides that you presented in
the garage
do you recall the primary takeaways or
oh sure in fact i have a set of them to
this day
amazing
if you'd want to
post them on your website for your
audience i'd definitely love to do that
so we'll follow up and put those in the
show notes
let's do that why did you present that
to them was it to try to provide them
with a framework
for
ultimately
executing on a business model once they
identified one was it for some other
purpose
it was simply so that they could achieve
operating excellence
maintaining their culture as they grew
faster than anyone
ever had attempted before they may not
have known how they were going to make
money but they were very clear on their
mission and their values their mission
was to organize all the world's
information and make it readily
available everywhere
that's
pretty
breathtaking and ambitious and timeless
and true still today
to do that
while you're trying to
constantly improve the product and
recruit more talented people to go
faster
you want to have a
sturdy reliable way to
set goals check goals get everybody
aligned
around really owning and wanting to do
the right thing
i'll never forget some sessions i had
with larry page every quarter
for a long time for many years he would
review the individual objectives and key
results for every engineer at google
this would take him a day and a half or
more
per quarter
and of course he walked the talk he
would stand up in front of all the
employees eric larry
sergey and they'd show their individual
okrs graded as well as the okrs for the
entire organization and here's one
remarkable thing tim
those goals those okrs to the best of my
knowledge
never
leaked
it was part of the google culture that
that information which is very business
sensitive and confidential could be
shared
and kept within the organization
that is really remarkable just to try to
wrap your head around especially as they
began to scale
and add such tremendous head count at
the time if we could peg a date to it
more or less what year
was that first
deck at first okr session yeah
the first okr session with google was in
1999.
okay this is two years before i moved to
silicon valley and part of what
impresses me about your
career and experience is the the breadth
of
investing that you've done you've
invested in so many different sectors so
many different types of companies you
mentioned this was the largest capital
commitment
that the partnership had made to date
why
did you decide that was warranted and
how did you convince
the other partners that this was a good
idea
well it was certainly a group decision
and while i was the advocate there were
co-sponsors it was a controversial
decision
which is true i think of many great
investment decisions if it's obvious
then
someone else will have done it before or
everyone's doing it
but this was you'll recall i think about
the 18th
search engine
and
kleiner had invested
in an earlier portal
and search
company called excite
which became excited at home
and so
there was some
coordination i guess i'll call it or
maybe just best practices of making sure
that
excite had bid to try to acquire google
in the early days
i think they offered a million dollars
which the founders
wisely rejected
and google had a stronger technology
by far than excite did
and so
the idea of an 18th search engine didn't
phase me one bit
i'll never forget
my first conversation with larry page
when i asked him how big google would be
and he told me 10 billion dollars
remember now this is around
1998.
this is at a time when you still dialed
up to get into the internet i about fell
out of my chair i said larry surely you
mean market cap at 10 billion he said no
john i mean revenues
search
today
is just in the very beginning in fact
it's a very crummy experience i want the
search system to be able to answer any
question that's asked of it and indeed
to anticipate what our users want to
know
so
i'm a sucker for
big ideas and big dreams
and certainly google was one of the
largest that i'd ever seen
and was part of that just looking at
the numbers they already had was it your
engineer's assessment of the technology
i understand that
larry and sergey i mean they're called
the wonder twins for a reason right
they're incredibly impressive
and
there is that sort of force of
intellectual horsepower and personality
but as the 18th search engine were there
just characteristics of
the technology or the growth trajectory
they were unlike anything that you'd
seen before
well beyond the brilliance of the
founders
and
my belief which i was shouting from the
treetops that the internet
at that time had been under hyped
it was going to be very very large there
were three other
key
observations the first of which was
their search was much better
this notion of pagerank which was
we're going to return results not based
on keywords but on
how many pages point to the page
for the answer in question
produced a demonstrably better
experience
the second observation was
because of that their numbers were off
the chart and so
the growth rate was unlike anything we'd
seen
for any other service and finally coming
from
the technology industries from intel and
networking companies it didn't take a
great leap of imagination
to
see that
search well done could transform
everything and so we put those together
and
that compelled us to fight to win the
opportunity to invest
well that turned out that turned out
quite well
i'd say on almost every level is it true
and i should probably know this but
since you mentioned it page rank
in part was page rank
named pagerank because
of the last name of larry page or did
that have nothing yes yeah absolutely it
was
the the founders in fact the whole place
is still a great deal of fun but the
original name for the product i think at
stanford was back rub
back reverse ranking links of
relevance
oh that is uh that is very clever i want
to
and we're going to keep of course coming
back to this
revisit okrs could you give a concrete
example real or hypothetical of what
a business okr
might look like it could be in any
format and then perhaps give an example
of how you might apply okrs to your
personal life one business one personal
could my business one be applying okrs
to the climate crisis
yes good let's do the climate crisis
first and foremost
so
look there's three numbers that we've
got to remember about the climate crisis
this is the engineer in me speaking
those numbers are
59
net zero
in 2050
and simply put tim we're dumping 59
gigatons of greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere every year
as if it's some kind of free and open
sewer and that number has got to go to
zero by 2050 we're told by the science
if we're going to avoid catastrophic
irreversible climate crisis and so the
number one objective of the speed and
scale plan
is to drive 59 gigatons to zero
that's great
that's a goal
the world has lots of goals with respect
to climate and with respect to this
really important area
but
a long list of menu options is not a
plan
a list of hopes and dreams or despair
and anger that's not a plan either
and so what speed and scale is is a plan
i'll describe it for you and by the way
you can get this plan for free at
speedandskill.com right now
just have the listeners go there and
click on it but it shows the five areas
where we have objectives
which are to reduce emissions
from 59 to zero
simply
and we know this electrified
transportation decarbonize the grid
fix our food systems
not only what we eat but how we grow
what we eat
protect nature
clean up industry
which is how we make steel
cement
and other dirty carbon emitting things
and then finally tim because these first
five
only add up to 49 gigatons per year we
have another 10 gigatons of carbon that
we must remove
we will continue emitting carbon but we
need to get to net zero
we've got to do this by 2050
or we're out of time if we do it by 2060
or 2070 it's too late
this is a rate race that we're in so
there are four objectives
in this plan
that will enable us give us a fighting
chance to get this done in time the
first of those is to win at politics and
policy
the second
is to turn movements
like greta thundberg's global school
strike
into real action
the third
very near and dear to my heart is to
innovate invent
and the fourth
is to invest to invest a lot more money
in it
now you said john give me an example of
these
for a business kind of problem and on
the reverse side of this poster which is
available for free
are 55
measurable time-bound accountable key
results
date specific
with the amount of gigatons that will be
removed if we take one of these on
so i'll just start at the beginning here
in electrifying transportation
the goal is to reduce eight gigatons of
emissions to two
by twenty fifty and we're going to do
that through six key results i'll just
read you the first of them the first of
these key results is to get price
performance parity between electric
vehicles and internal combustion engine
vehicles and do that by 2024 in the us
just two years from now and in india and
china by 2030 just eight years from now
and specifically to get it to 35 000
and 11 000 respectively i want to tell
you this tim if we don't get that done
we are not going to make it to net zero
and the story is the same for 55 of
these
quantitative measurable key results
john can you speak more to what it means
to be too late so if we don't
reduce 59 to net zero by 2050
what is it what is what does it look
like
for things to be too late does that mean
uh ultimately planetary collapse
irretrievably so uh does it mean
something else could you paint a picture
for us
the picture
is devastating
one of the things that inspired me to do
this work was a recent book by david
wallace wells called the uninhabitable
earth i recommend it it's a terrifying
picture of the coming devastation from
global warming
the writer's predictions might seem
extreme
but just look at the evidence all around
us from the last couple of years
we've had devastating hurricanes
biblical floods record wildfires and
heat waves massive droughts
and since we won't be getting to net
zero anytime soon
it's safe to say that our future is
going to be even worse
according to the latest report from the
un's intergovernmental panel on climate
change we have a global carbon budget
of 400 gigatons
400 gigatons that's the maximum that we
can emit
to have a decent chance to limit global
warming to one and a half degrees
celsius
and avoid an irreversible climate
disaster
now tim at the current rate for global
emissions we're going to blow through
that budget in less than seven years
that's why we're joining jeff bezos
christiana figueres and john kerry and
saying we must cut drastically now
this is the decisive decade if we don't
get a 50 reduction by 2030
we're screwed
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
ship station the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff online than ever
before all of these trends to e-commerce
have been accelerated due to covid and
much more if you're an e-commerce seller
are you ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest easiest
and most affordable way to manage and
ship your orders in just a few clicks
you're managing orders printing out
discounted shipping labels and getting
your products out fast happier holidays
for you and your customers shipstation
takes the hassle out of holiday shipping
no matter where you're selling on amazon
etsy your website via shopify or other
platforms shipstation brings all of your
orders into one simple interface and
shipstation works with all of the major
carriers usps fedex ups even
international you can compare and choose
the best shipping solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved for
large fortune 500 companies it's no
wonder that shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers and right
now my listeners that's you guys can try
shipstation free for 60 days when you
use offer code tim just go to the
homepage shipstation.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in tim tim that's it go to
shipstation.com then enter offer code
tim
shipstation.com make ship happen
so let me ask a question because
i'm sometimes asked by listeners what
keeps me up at night and for the last
few years especially the last year
it has been
climate change and just looking at the
canaries in the coal mine
and where the trend lines are headed i
mean that sort of existential distress
has been
palpable for me
and in my exploration of different
technologies different startups
different policy makers different
policies for that matter there's no
shortage of will
proposals
to
address climate change there are many
movements a lot of people are upset
and trying to get attention but it's
unclear to what end
why has there been so little progress
on
getting closer to net zero
well
it's a very hard and complex problem
but there are three really big rocks big
obstacles that are standing in our way
first we've got to overcome the
entrenched incumbents that now rely on
fossil fuels and that includes
multinational oil companies
and heavy coal consumers like china and
petrol states like russia
china recently announced it's going to
stop building coal-fired power plants in
other countries
but it also needs to accelerate its
commitment to get off coal inside china
this is why the
climate summit in glasgow cup
26 is so important
the second big challenge is to speed
innovations for example in batteries and
in clean energy so that we can turn the
green premium into a green discount
we're already at the point where it's
going to clearly cost more to ruin the
planet than to save it
but we need additional breakthroughs to
get global adoption of clean energy
with speed and scale
the third obstacle is that up to now we
haven't seen a pragmatic action plan to
fight climate change
we have not had a plan that shows
exactly how we're going to get those 59
billion tons of carbon out of the
atmosphere in time
speed and scale
is our attempt to fill that gap
let's dig into
a number of the bullets that you
mentioned specifically the innovate
slash invent and invest categories the
reason i'm focusing on those is we can
come back to win at politics and policy
and to converting movements to action
but since a lot of people listening may
feel like they're in a position
either as a founder or an engineer or
otherwise to innovate and invent or
they're in a position with capital to
invest i'd love to approach this from a
retrospective if you're open to it so i
sent some of my rapid fire
common questions to you and your team
ahead of time and one of those questions
is how is an apparent failure
set you up for later success or do you
have a favorite failure and the cliff
notes here which i'd love to hear you
expand on was 1 billion in cleantech and
then fisker tesla
could you expand
on that because you've been in the game
of investing in this space for a long
time a lot has changed over
the last decade plus
but could you speak to that answer for
me this all started 15 years ago you'll
remember then your audience will al
gore's movie an inconvenient truth
definitely and right after seeing that
movie i had some friends over with my
family for dinner and i got a challenge
from my teenage daughter
mary said to me
dad
i'm scared and i'm angry your generation
created this problem
you better fix it
and tim
i didn't know what to say the room went
silent
as i dug into this
i'd never seen a problem this is 2006 so
vast and complex
i'm the electrical engineer entrepreneur
who loves to tackle big problems so what
i did my partners was to set out to find
fund and accelerate the innovators
you're talking about who would have
solutions to the climate crisis
we couldn't just sit back in our offices
on sandhill road
and wait for business plans to come in
we we searched the world from the mojave
deserts to the brazilian rainforest we
convened meetings of top scientists we
advocated for more funding for r d
we met with hundreds actually nearly a
thousand entrepreneurs and even hired
my personal climate hero al gore to join
kleiner perkins we invested a billion
dollars starting in 2006
in a hundred different clean tech
companies
and most of them failed i've got a lot
of scar tissue
we had our share of failures
and
failures come with the territory in the
innovation business but we stood by
these entrepreneurs tim
and that billion dollars today
is worth three billion
what i learned from that experience
is that
cleantech takes more time more money
more guts with longer horizons
and
the innovators the entrepreneurs
need to in andy grove speak be
ruthlessly intellectually honest about
where the risks are in their venture
get those risks up front
remove them with early dollars
and if the risks are way downstream
think twice or even three times about
pursuing that
because it will take longer
it will take more capital
you'll be fighting incumbents there will
be a groundswell of
public demand and appetite and
ultimately i believe institutional
support
today 2021 15 years later are very
different times than 2006
but
this is not
for the faint of heart
it's for the people who are
full of heart full of head and
are devoted as so many are to using
their entrepreneurial and creative
skills
to literally change the world i would
love to
look at this a little further because
i'm committing a lot of my own capital
to
startups who i hope can move the needle
with
getting to net zero and in many other
capacities
and it strikes me that
there are a lot of different
approaches one can take and one of the
things that makes me optimistic now as
opposed to say 15 years ago and i'd love
to just get your sanity check and have
you add to this because you're so much
more experienced
is that
we're starting to see a lot of companies
where the unit economics are so
attractive and the products they are
creating and services
so compelling from an economic
standpoint also the narrative has
changed culturally
that they can very quickly
generate profit and be self-sustaining
where it seemed like in the earlier days
maybe even in 2006
it was really important to play
the
policy
angle and to
look for regulatory or legal change as
well as maybe even possible government
subsidies
to support a lot of companies and i'm
just wondering if some of those changes
are things that you agree with or have
observed or if other material changes
have made
this sector even more attractive for
investment now
tim the sector is a lot more attractive
now than it was in 2006.
the
market need is more evident
the
technologies are in higher volume and
therefore more cost competitive even
without subsidy
though
i want to say that
for most
new energy
cleantech startups cost is king that's
the area in which you must work the
hardest to innovate
because of something bill gates calls
the green premium
most
carbon free
solutions cost more than their carbon
drenched counterparts
in the years following al gore's movie
2006 through 2008 2009
the country entered the great recession
and except for some
loan guarantees from the obama
administration
venture funding really
was almost extinguished
just last year by contrast venture
capitalists invested 23 billion dollars
into more than a thousand clean tech
startups
in this year
2021 startups have raised 16 billion
dollars
in 250
ventures that's in just
the first part of the year over the last
year more than a thousand investment
firms have joined in this mission
so
it's very
vibrant the paths are clear the
transportation sector is leading the way
everything from early stage series a
deals to spax these have all doubled in
size
late stage growth funds are now
available and so
the scale and pace of venture funding is
remarkable
but
we need a lot more financing of all
types
seed
venture
late stage
project financing and philanthropic
capital and there are stories
from each of those five sectors
or components and key results that make
up the invest part of our plan could you
give another example could be personal
could be from
a past company that folks might
recognize whether it's a google or an
amazon could really be anything but
could you give another
concrete example of what okrs might look
like for those people at home are
thinking
how they might create oak chairs for
themselves and we're going to come back
to
discussing
speed and scale and the various
multi-pronged approach but i'd love to
just make it exceptionally clear to
everybody listening what okrs
are and like you said how they differ
from
what people might consider goal setting
okrs
stands for objectives
and key results
the objective is what we're trying to
achieve
the key result is how we're going to get
it done
one of my favorite okr stories is in my
first book called measure what matters
and that's when
larry page and sergey brin turned to
sundar pishai
who at the time was a google product
manager
and they said to him they'd like to
create the next generation
web browser and application development
environment
which eventually became google chrome
now syndar's genius was to translate
that
into
both the correct objective
build the world's best browser and the
correct key results
so how will you measure what will be the
key results to tell you that you've
built the best browser
sundar could have chosen
any number of measures like
click-throughs or revenues or how many
times people came back to using chrome
and by the way any one of those nuanced
and different key results would have
taken his effort
in a different direction
what sundar did brilliantly is say we're
simply going to measure success by the
number of users so he boiled it down
into a bold and beautiful okr
where
the the main key result
in the beginning was to reach 20 million
weekly active users by the end of the
year starting from zero by the way this
was a moon shot for sure in fact tim do
you remember the internet back in 2008
it was
very very slow we were using internet
explorer
and the chrome team missed their target
comes with the territory when you set
really audacious goals
so what matters is what sundar then did
did he give up
no
he kept the same timeless objective to
build the world's best browser
but he set even more aggressive stretch
goals
by 2010 he said his key result would be
111 million weekly active users
and they made that key result now you
also asked about a personal okr
i'll share one out of my own life i'm
the proud father of two amazing
daughters
and raising them i wanted to be sure
that we had a healthy family life
and so i set that as an objective have a
healthy family life
the key result
was to be home for dinner 20 nights a
month by 6 p.m and to be fully present
no screens
that was definitely a stretch goal and i
i'd say i made it only about 70 percent
of the time
but when we were together at dinner we
were there with
phones off internet off
and able to be centered and focused
on what really matters
i have to
ask you a follow-up on
becoming a parent and building a family
and that's in part this is purely
selfish but i am
how old am i 44
in a committed relationship
talking very seriously about kids
and
there's another question i ask often
which is what advice would you give to
your 30 year old self and
the note that i got back was have kids
sooner and i thought to myself well damn
i really
need to hit the pavement running
and hear more about this maybe in the
opposite order so could you just
elaborate on that answer please
sure i think it starts with
how you make meaning out of life and
we each have our own choices there my
north star is you make meeting
with and
for others
that
life alone is is one great big missed
opportunity
my personal
regret
is that ann and i started our family at
around age 40
instead of age 30. 30 to 40 was a great
time for
my career but i think
we could have
raised one more
amazing daughter or son
if we started at it sooner
could you say more about that i know
this might sound
strange as a question or as an as an ask
but
what does it feel like to be a parent
for you maybe it's an intuitive
sort of instinctive response that is
hard to put into words but you're also
an engineer so i'd love to hear you say
a bit more on making meaning
particularly as it relates to to kids
and family
i'm reminded of something that andy
grove told me
when he retired from intel
after the most amazing career i mean
this man democratized the microcomputer
chip
and built an amazing company
i said gosh andy i bet you're gonna and
by the way i was working to try to get
him to join the board of amazon or
google at the time
and he said no that's for another
generation to do
i said aren't you going to miss intel
enormously when you retire
and he said john
i'll miss it
but not so much
because
i'm a grandparent and when i look into
the eyes of my grandchildren
i get to see the future and he didn't
say anything more than that
but
it clearly
is how
he
made meaning
over the sweep of a lifetime
so
what was your question again the
question was
how you broadly think about making
meaning and i had in my mind of course
how that relates to kids and
family but i think that as
people who are listening get barraged
with
polarized bad news day in and day out
there are increased levels of
anxiety
existential distress
and
i think a lot of people are asking what
the point of it all is i'm not saying
that's a good question but there's a
certain malaise and i think finding
meaning
is an important
countervailing force or antidote to that
malaise and so it's really just a broad
question about how you
how you create meaning for yourself
i do it in relation with others with
family with
entrepreneurs that i get to work with
with friends with policy makers i'm a
introverted engineer but
also
avid networker
i'm talking about the kinds of networks
that
are
built and sustained
over a lifetime how do you make meaning
out of life
i currently think that i
may require kids to fully answer that
question well
and a friend of mine
once told me the story he's in his his
60s now maybe actually no he's in his
early 70s grandparent and he said when
he had his first child which he had late
his brother said to him
welcome to the human race that was his
comment when he had his first kid and
i feel like there's probably a lot to
that so how do i create meaning right
now i mean this might sound really
strange but i try to
i make meaning out of bonds with others
and trying to alleviate suffering
that
is that could be the suffering of pain
it could be the suffering of attachment
to outcomes it could be the
suffering of
uncertainty but
that's where i am now
we'll see where it goes so right now for
me making meaning
is to give a healthy climate to the
future generations
i believe we owe it to them
for them to enjoy the
opportunities in nature and in the lives
that we have
i think i'm also converging on that and
that that will be more palpable for me
once i have kids and i don't want to
take us off track
but i remember
hearing from someone who's focused on
artificial intelligence or the threats
of artificial intelligence say that
whenever he's discussing it with anyone
he asks them two questions one is
do you know how to code and the other is
do you have kids and he said unless the
answer is yes to both of those he really
doesn't spend a lot of time
in the conversation but
coming back to climate crisis and
solutions
and you're talking about building
relationships
you've mentioned two names al gore bill
gates
where do you have differences of opinion
the three of you on
the state of affairs or the value of
different solutions and approaches where
have you guys had spirited debates
first of all and this is
really true
they each of them have given
for all practical purposes their lives
to this mission
the climate crisis
yes bill cares enormously about public
health and health care
but if we have a billion climate
refugees
the people least responsible for this
problem
are going to pay the highest price and
they're least capable of dealing with it
and that's the world's poor
i am probably
not as optimistic as bill or al are
but i'm very hopeful
and
my concern is that on this
quest we are fast running out of time al
especially and bill as well
are stunned by the
declines in the costs of
solar energy and wind renewable
alternatives
to fossil fuels which
the iaea among others have said we've
got to stop burning to make electricity
but i think
it's really a balance between deploying
more now of what we have and we know
works
while we're investing for the new
it's the now and the new
i think
bill gates has great confidence
in the new and the role of innovation
and i share a lot of that optimism with
him
i do think there's
to your earlier point about motivation
besides
al and bill who are working this full
time i'm really struck by something that
barack obama said about the climate
crisis
which is and our obligation
he said we're the first generation to
feel the effects of climate change
and the last generation who can do
something about it which really conveys
i think the responsibility and the
urgency
that we have to
to tackle this problem
let's discuss action steps calls to
action this
audience meaning my fine listeners
really span across every possible sector
they are found in private sector in
public sector
positions of
policy influence governmental influence
they're everywhere they're all over the
place and there are many people who are
not in those positions but nonetheless
very interested
in
trying to contribute in whatever way
that they can are there any particular
requests you would like to make of
people in the audience or suggested next
actions that you might have what a great
question and the answer is absolutely
yes
look tim
i wrote this book for leaders everywhere
in all walks of life
it's for your audience for sure for
entrepreneurs and for activists and for
philanthropists and investors
but it is also for
teachers and their students and for
teenagers and their grandparents
and your children and your children's
children to come
but most of all
i wrote this book
for the leader inside of each of you
listening to us
and remember jim collins's great
definition of leadership he says
leaders inspire others
to want to do
what must be done
they inspire others to act and so while
we've got to act individually you should
switch to electric appliances if you can
afford them buy an electric vehicle eat
less beef individual action is not going
to be enough
not nearly enough
if we're going to get to net zero
we need massive global action and an
example of that
is to pressure our utilities to clean up
their electric grids
that's collective action
make electric vehicles cheaper and
available at scale that takes collective
action
transform our food system
eliminate food waste that takes
collective action
so we really need
the leader inside each of your listeners
to decide
this is their north star
and then they're going to organize
to support candidates who are committed
to climate action they're going to push
their employer to make net zero
commitment they're going to
[Music]
and in fact become entrepreneurs who
innovate like crazy we need investors to
push companies
for big emissions cuts all of this needs
to happen
and we have to get halfway there by
2030. we've got to improve
at least eight percent per year
against
a monumentally hard goal
because
we're at 59 gigatons right now
that's going to get worse before it gets
better
we're going to go from 7 billion to 10
billion people
and so
i like to say this is the mother of all
markets it's also the mother of all
problems but we can do it especially if
we've got a clear plan and
my understanding is that people can find
free resources a lot of what we've
talked about in terms of options for
action
that you and
certainly your team have
thought through based on okrs and
timelines deliverables etc they can find
those at speedandscale.com is that the
best resource for people
that's certainly a place to start get
the plan there also get this book and
i'm not saying it to sell the book but
there's a bibliography the book doesn't
have appendices it has resources and so
there's another 40 or so books
there's every advocacy group there's
every investor that's working in the
field i think of this
book as a field manual a guide that i'm
determined to update on the web and in
print form until we get this job done
the work by the way i want to give
credit to the
teams of policy experts and
scientists
i'm an engineer tim and i have a hard
problem with words it's really hard for
me to write and write things well so the
truth is i cheat in easily half of this
book
are verbatim conversations with 35
different climate leaders
stories from
maribera who's running general motors
and what it was like for her to decide
to stop making internal combustion
engines
or
take christiana figueres who ran the
paris accords the last time she tells in
the book what her hopes and dreams are
for the coming glasgow cop26
or
an entrepreneur bruce niles who shut
down more coal-fired power plants in the
us than i think any individual so 35
different conversations
a field guide
a plan an action plan for solving the
climate crisis
so it sounds like people will not only
get
inspiration which is sort of that
initial push in a sense but also the
instructions
so that when they're pushed in a
direction or pulled in a direction they
actually have
practical next steps that they can take
and certainly two of those
right now would be
going to speedskill.com and getting
speed and scale subtitle and action plan
for solving our climate crisis now this
is something i
am thinking about all the time so i was
very very happy to
have you on john i've been looking
forward to this conversation i think
it's a critical conversation maybe the
critical conversation
that more people should be having right
now
is there anything else that you would
like to
say any closing comments any requests of
my audience before we
bring this conversation to a close
yes there is and thanks for giving me
the opportunity to do that
i think
it's important and been an important
part of my learning
to realize that climate change is the
world's biggest
inequality machine
i said before those that suffer the most
who will suffer the most did the least
to cause this and those who caused it
the most are best equipped to escape the
consequences
and so our work in this field needs to
be guided and grounded in a deep sense
of climate justice and equity
both at home and around the world
that all sounds great
what it really means is we need to
acknowledge the differences between the
developing
[Music]
poor countries and the developed
countries because there are vast
differences disparities in their ability
to move away from fossil fuels and how
fast they can do this
specifically the countries who have
contributed the most to the crisis
and the u.s is the greatest
really must help finance the transition
for developing nations
we've also got to be mindful
of the millions of everyday workers
whose livelihoods are tied to fossil
fuels they deserve retraining
quality job opportunities in pollution
free neighborhoods
the united states must go first
and so
just in the last couple of days
biden agreed to double the u.s
commitment
towards the 100 billion per year fund
that the developing world
and the paris accords called for
but it's not yet enough
if there's a rallying cry for where we
stand today on this
existential crisis
this mission
it's
it's not enough
we've got to act with greater speed and
scale
hence the name
hence the very apt
title speed and scale john doerr
i have followed you very closely since
before i moved to silicon valley it's
such a pleasure to spend time together
everyone can find you on twitter at john
door d-o-e-r-r
and the book again is speed and scale
speedingscale.com is where people can
learn more
and i really appreciate you taking the
time today john this is an important
message and i'm glad to have you out
there pounding the drum and having these
conversations
tim your creation of community
and cause is a great gift
to this campaign and i just
i'd like your audience to share with me
and with us what they're doing about
this what okrs they are creating and
have them send them to me i'm john at
speedingscale.com
we're all in this together
we are definitely
in this together
and i imagine you will get some okrs via
email so thank you for that and to
everybody listening i will include the
links to everything we've discussed
resources
and more perhaps we'll have that
photograph of larry and sergey and
yourself in the garage
and perhaps even that initial
presentation as a
as a lure to get people into the
resources at tim.log forward slash
podcast
and until next time take care be safe
think long-term long-termism is
important and we are all in this
together
and until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim dot blog slash friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix sleep and
their mattresses which i've been using
since 2017. i have two of them upstairs
from where i'm sitting at this moment
and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form
a-l-l-f-o-r-m and they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores so i'm
sitting in my living room right now and
it's entirely all form furniture i've
got two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional couch and i'll come
back to that you can pick your fabric
they're all spill stained and scratch
resistant the sofa color the color of
the legs the sofa size the shape to make
sure it's perfect for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular and easy these things fit
together kind of like lego pieces
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight seat sectional so
there's something for everyone you can
also start small and kind of build on
top of it if you want to get a smaller
couch and then build out on it which is
actually in a way what i did because i
can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman in a matter of about 60 seconds
it's pretty rad so i mentioned i have
all these different things in this room
i use the natural leg finish which is
their lightest color and i dig it and
i've been using these things hours and
hours and hours every single day so
i am using what i am sharing with you
guys and if getting a sofa without
trying it in store sounds risky you
don't need to worry all form sofas are
delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it that's
more than three months and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for free and
give you a full refund your sofa frame
also has a forever warranty that's
literally forever so check it out take a
look they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have imagined and i'm very
very happy so to find your perfect sofa
check out allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout that's allforum.com
tim and use code tim at checkout
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked all the time
what i would take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens i view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance i recommended it
in fact in the 4-hour body this is more
than 10 years ago and i did not get paid
to do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multivitamins multi-mineral greens
complex probiotics and prebiotics for
gut health and immunity formula
digestive enzymes adaptogens and much
more i usually take it once or twice a
day just to make sure i've covered my
bases if i miss anything i'm not aware
of of course i focus on nutrient-dense
meals to begin with that's the basis but
athletic greens makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when whole foods aren't
readily available from travel packets i
always have them in my bag when i'm
zipping around right now athletic greens
is giving my audience a special offer on
top of their all-in-one formula which is
a free vitamin d supplement and five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d i found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so adding a
vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support support your immunity gut
health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
[Applause]
you